lobby of Ramsey solutions Dan and char
are with us hey guys how are you
welcome welcome so where do you guys
live we're in Columbia South Carolina
fun and you're here to do a debt-free
scream yes sir and how much have you
paid off Dave we've paid off one hundred
and twenty thousand dollars in six years
but eighty four thousand of that in the
last 20 months whoa very cool
making what kind of money we started at
sixty thousand yeah now we're making
over a hundred thousand dollars
excellent excellent what do y'all do for
a living Dave I'm an actuary okay and I
see home what the girls all right and
you have three girls tell me their names
and ages grace is seven Lexi is four and
Evie is two
all right very fun so that's a long trip
all the way from South Carolina with
three low kids I love it so but you want
to mark this huh yeah you want to mark
it at least in a couple of them's mines
we'll see who remembers it later but I
have they been involved in the getting
out of debt process do they know
anything about this yes they do
we've we've been promising them that
when we got out of debt we'd take them
to Disneyland so that's a good carrot
very cool
so what happened in the six years and
tell me about the 20 month thing what
tell me you're all story sure
so yes about six years ago dave is when
we we kind of first heard about your
plan you know prior to that we had you
know we had lived on a budget and we had
you know starting to put into into play
Scott's principles for handling finances
we always felt like we're just kind of
do but trying to do everything all at
once we've never had a clear plan of
what we're doing that's when we're
introduced to your plan and and so we
got we got into it right away six years
ago we paid off Shara's student loan
there was about $10,000 student loan and
we were able to pay that off right away
cool and move right into you know save
him for the emergency fund and investing
and so forth and you know we were
plotting along for a few years there we
were following the steps we were you
know saving to make purchases you know
doing the investing and you know about
20 months ago
is when we really kicked it into gear
and decided we needed to pay off her
house and there's a few things that kind
of led to that you know we had a couple
of really good friends who we saw do the
exact same thing to really close
families paid off their debt including
their home and we were very inspired and
encouraged by them and you know guy was
really just impressing in our hearts
that we needed to get out of the slavery
of debt you know proverbs 22:7
applies the more than just consumer debt
so you decided to knock out your house
and everything we sure did okay and
that's when he kicked it in 20 months
ago correct yeah okay all right very fun
so
Chardin comes in and goes okay I'm gonna
turn the heat up on this thing what'd
you say
actually I was more than 100 on this
he's making it sound like his idea the
way you're doing all the presenting here
yeah I mean there is a little resistance
Sam is the spender but um the actuarial
spender yeah that's an oxymoron I'm a
super nerd but I love spending yeah me
too yeah so um but I mean God really
just put it on his heart to I was a lot
of prayer and and we just did it I don't
know so what's your house worth it was
about one hundred fifteen hundred twenty
excellent excellent it's paid for you
have no debt in the world and you guys
are how old 33 that's amazing and making
over a hundred a year you can do
anything you want to do now you've lived
like no one else now you can live and
give like no one else these girls you've
completely changed their family tree I
mean if you play all the way through
with this kind of income and no debt
that's some serious money that you're
gonna have invested and some serious
money you're gonna be able to give and
things you'll be able to do for others
so including completely change your
family tree so way to go you guys is
that all sunk in it has it was you know
when we first I feel like when we first
did it it didn't sink in for me at least
it's been a couple months now and it
really has sunk in just the freedom that
we have having no debt yeah completely
sunk in no it's amazing
so char what do you tell why
out there that are trying to get their
husbands on board what do you tell him
um lots of Prayer um I could have you
know like argued or whatever but it was
just down on my knees and praying and
I'm sorry motional but I came through
and you know he's our provider he's our
provision through the whole thing and
and so I'm just grateful for what he's
done in our lives in our marriage and
and honestly it was a tough road and I'm
glad to be on the other side and I mean
we did go through a time of just
struggle of disagreeing and but God just
was there through the whole thing and I
feel like we're just better people for
it and I'm just so thankful for the
process not just the end results of
paying off her house but the process
that the Lord took us through and the
journey that we were on so then one way
I know that I can measure somebody being
a good man and you definitely are a good
man
is if they married up well done sir well
done alright girls gather around let's
get ready to do a debt-free scream Dan
and char and Gracie and Lexi and Evie I
love it a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars paid off in six years making 60
up to over a hundred now all the way
from Columbia South Carolina count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
oh love it love it love it
way to go you - way to go